i know you've worked with edward james
almost
as an actor and also when he directed
you correct and also i'm not sure if
you've ever worked with eva longoria but
people like that powerhouses that what
do you observe from them when you see
them on set how even if you're you're
not even engaging with them but what do
you see
edward james almost has always been
proactive and he has instilled in me to
to push forward
he's a fighter he's like you've got to
keep moving you gotta make your own
projects you gotta make it happen for
yourself so he's truly inspiring
i did end up working with eva longoria
um
and she was wonderful she was a
sweetheart she really takes care of the
crew she's respectful and just
a delight
how
they
helped me
was
by being respectful and appreciating
the space that we were in both as actors
and
also that project that i worked with eva
longoro is also predominantly latino so
we just
had a good time had a good time
it's just a given i mean we just show up
on not that sets are that aren't latino
aren't fun i mean a lot of the sets are
fun but there is something about
you know
a predominantly latino cast and crew
that that just changes it a little bit
it's almost like you have ketchup which
is fun
then you have salsa it just has so much
more
that's that's the only thing you can
compare it to right now